there have been a bunch of stories
floating around of Russian use of social
media and Internet company technology
this includes Facebook and Twitter and
Google as part of their influence
campaign around the 2016 election and
there's this common thread where any
time these huge internet companies are
asked about hey it looks as though the
Russians did this with Facebook or this
with Twitter to try to influence the
election results you see very little
said by those companies and there have
been some really specific reports like
for example a recent one in BuzzFeed
called Twitter was warned repeatedly
about this fake account run by a Russian
troll farm and refused to take it down
and people have been emailing me
suggesting that the fact that Facebook
or Twitter or Google don't really say
much about alleged Russian use of their
platform is indicative that those
platforms were complicit in Russian
interference presumably to help Donald
Trump I don't think that that's the
truth at all the reason that these
companies like Facebook and Twitter and
Google don't really want to comment
don't really want to get involved in
what Russia may or may not have done
with the platform's technology platforms
and ad targeting that they allow is
because those companies don't want it
exposed how advanced their technology is
because it would create public uproar we
have many reasons to speculate about how
much Google knows about us about how
much Facebook knows about us and about
how they can really influence public
opinion on whatever issue they want
merely through the use of the algorithms
that they've they've developed those are
the real secrets that companies like
Facebook and others want to protect
because more than likely if the public
was made aware of the power that these
companies have how much they know and
how specifically they can target and
surgically influence public opinion
people would probably lose their minds
and start calling for the corporate
death penalty or worse again some of
these companies and it reminds me of
YouTube's ad pocalypse the YouTube D
monetization cry
started at the beginning of April of
2017 and right away you had right-wing
youtubers saying this is a political
attack by Google against right-wingers
and he also had many left wingers saying
this is a political attack by Google
against alternative left-wing ideas the
reality is it wasn't either it was
Google and through their platform of
YouTube trying to secure their money
stream to the best extent they can in
order to avoid losing major advertisers
now this isn't an excuse we should be
scared of the power that these companies
have but don't misinterpret Facebook's
lack of interest in commenting on how
Russia might have influenced the
election using Facebook ads don't see
that and interpret it as Oh face book is
in the tank for Russia they might be
they might not be don't interpret it as
being left or right they are in the the
tank kind of similarly to Donald Trump
for income market share and power and I
think it's really important that we all
remember that send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by
hellofresh which is a meal kit delivery
service that will shop plan and deliver
to you step-by-step recipes and pre
measured ingredients so you can just
cook eat and enjoy as many of you know I
don't have the time to spend all night
in my kitchen I've got to get to my
YouTube live streams so it's great for
me that hellofresh recipes only take
about 30 minutes start to finish that's
a good amount of time for me a lot of
one pot recipes so you don't have to
dirty a whole bunch of dishes minimal
cleanup and there's actually a 20 minute
meal on the menu every single week in
case you don't have more time than that
I am busy
so I like the 20 to 30 minute component
I also hate wasting food
I really dislike wasting food and that's
what I love about hellofresh they send
you the exact amount of each ingredient
that you need so you don't end up
tossing into the trash
half a head of garlic or your leftover
green onions or whatever else it is that
you don't know how to use and in
addition to that hello freshers recipes
are really great they are chef curated
they change weekly they've got the
classic plan with a wide variety of meat
fish and seasonal produce and they also
have the veggie plan vegetarian recipes
with plant-based proteins and the family
plan quick and easy meals that the
entire family will love plus they have
the kid-tested recipe selection don't
even get me started on that really
really convenient really great recipes
one example being the easy peasy ravioli
gratin with spinach thyme and parmesan
breadcrumbs you can save $30 off your
first week of hellofresh
at hellofresh comm with the promo code
here it is Pakman 30 that is hello fresh
com promo code PA KMA n3 zero